hello we're going in welcome to awesome
comics your one-stop shop for everything
comic book entertainment I am your host
Walter banana and today we're taking a
look at one of the Batman animated
series movies not Batman mask of the
phantasm we're talking about Batman and
mr. freeze sub-zero and to talk about it
today we have two special guests we're
cool with the one you're more familiar
with that's on the show it's Ayane Wade
what's up Anna how's it going good they
got the icicles I was going for like a
bat snow like I was I was going for a
theme guys I tried good combo and to my
left he's always behind the camera but
today's in front of the camera mr. Jim J
Rock that's what's up yeah pretty good
how's it feel to be in front of the
camera today
you feel a little out of place you know
right exactly under the table it comes
across
okay so sub-zero this was the second
animated feature that came out from the
team behind Bama in the animated series
it sort of is a wrap-up for mr. Freeze's
story arc but he then he does show up
again later in a couple other things
from this continuity but for all intents
and purposes this was supposed to be as
big send-off so let's talk about overall
what did you think will go overall then
positive negatives would you think Jim
overall this one overall actually
thought it was it was pretty good I I
had never seen it I remember when he
came out and I think I probably
dismissed it because it was after the
whole yeah and but I was I mean I was
always a big fan of the animated series
or at least the first like two three
seasons and yeah I was actually I
thought it was really good I thought
that was really well directed I thought
and the action sequences and stuff like
that were really well laid out and and
actually mr. freeze is one of my
favorite characters from the animated
series I thought he was like what they
did with him in the animated series
kind of put him like on that top bar for
me for his like Batman villains because
he was so sympathetic and stuff like
that but but also interesting you know I
mean you mean yeah character who you
drain all of the character out of
basically and make him this cold start
kind of character but actually give him
some humanity that was yeah I thought
that was they pulled it off really well
absolutely
Anna what do you think overall this one
I like this one a lot I think it's weird
that it's like double billed on a DVD
feature with massive phantasm because I
definitely don't think it's like that
caliber like in my opinion like but it's
very like Batman the Animated Series
which I love I got my back girl in it
I'm basically on board with you guys
with this it's I've seen it a couple
times now and I just re-watched it just
last night so stuff refresh my brain and
it was there's a couple sequences that
are great I mean like really well
animated and stuff really fluid some of
the best animation from the show end and
the series there's a couple in here that
just it looks great but yeah overall
it's not quite as epic as mask of the
phantasm it doesn't aim to tell Batman's
quasi origin it focuses on mr. freeze
which is it's still good and it still
has some really strong scenes and some
really strong motivation for mr. freeze
and a couple of the other characters so
it's cool it's just a smaller scale
story although the ending at the oral
Derek will talk about all that in
positives right now so pauses where did
some of the things you really liked
about a gym again I thought it was
really well directed I thought it was
some really interesting camera angles
and stuff like that that they decided to
go with and the action sequences were
super well laid out yeah the animation
for me was was pretty solid I felt like
there were times when it kind of dipped
it was like yeah there were moments
where the animation was like beautiful
and there are other moments where was
kind of like and took a backseat but for
the most part yeah I would say that the
directing and the storytelling element
of it was was great mm-hmm yeah I would
say like the parts that like are
animated while are animated to so well
and there's like a couple like not many
where it just didn't quite get it but I
felt kind of almost the same with the
story to me where some of it like when
it was engaging I was
into it and then when there was kind of
filler like like just having to get
through someone like the backstory I was
almost like bored by it and yeah we were
like a couple minutes and then it was
like right back into the story for me so
I felt like that overall a lot of it was
like really good and then I was like you
know okay we're back into it it was kind
of like it almost felt like it needed
like either needed to be like another
half-hour to kind of flesh out some
elements or shorten it up a little bit I
was like it was in a weird in-between it
was only six minutes or something to
where elements like they've kind of like
put some stuff in to kind of Pat it out
a little bit that they didn't fully
develop and I felt like and then there
were other like elements that was like
well you could probably you know cut
some of that out or elongated and you
know I just felt like the time wasn't
alive hey mister free stuff was all
really solid to me though I liked all of
his stuff I liked the opening to with
the polar bears yeah yeah I like open
sequence is really cool yeah with the
fishing yeah yeah definitely the polar
bears were pretty cool audition like it
just seems like it's like the polar bear
just like chill in a room - yeah like
they're just in a room and then oh yeah
like Oh like Fight Club it out
the opening of like title with the bat
symbol and everything they use the Tim
Burton music yeah it was it was
different by I liked it I was like it is
sort of like the first the first Burton
movie where it's sort of in the trenches
of the bat logo and that comes out you
see it's the Battle of when it kind of
did like a shorter version of that with
this and then it gets frozen over and
says sub-zero I thought that was pretty
cool opening title sequence so this was
also delayed let's talk about this
really quick it was delayed like almost
a year because of Batman and Robin
because of Arnold's bargain swaggin a
bargaining Arnold Schwarzenegger is
portrayed as mr. freeze and that the
whole critical reception to that I kind
of put a damper on one thing this was
missing was the ice puns interesting
that they delayed because at this time
the new Batman adventures which is
basically the fourth season of the
animated series is already out like the
year before so they were going with that
new style already the more streamlined
style of the last season on the show
that it was also in line with Superman
the animated series and this came out
and it had the old the first three
seasons look to it so that was kind of a
weird you know almost like a callback
but it's a callback to like two years
prior yeah so it was interesting that
they went back I always enjoyed this
animation style better than the more
structure and style of yeah yeah what do
you guys think of this style in
comparison to like the fourth season and
even like Justice League and stuff well
I think it it's just you have to like
think about it at like the time it came
out though it's almost like watching I
don't know like any animated show like
Family Guy and you go back and you watch
season one you're like oh this is
unbearable I can't play like I watched
this one came out but also the new stuff
is just so like computery done and it's
like doesn't have that like raw feeling
to it like so I would say this is almost
that same thing where it still has like
that warm but I like that yes I actually
like the other yeah the earlier seasons
I thought the animation was
yeah the fourth season the animation cat
threw me off a little bit I was yeah it
was a little hard for me to kind of like
I thought the characterization was right
there's still some great episodes and
yeah we're season but yeah I agree with
you that the tone of it kind of change
in the red sky yeah it was definitely a
change of pace but I'm glad that they
went with this for mr. freeze yeah yeah
I think that some of the chase sequences
- there's that big chase with Robin on
the big race and outside of cars on the
motorcycle and they integrated the 3d
stuff I thought it worked pretty well I
mean not perfect well I'm it does stand
out but at the time yes I thought it
worked pretty well I thought that was a
pretty thrilling action scene and mr.
freeze is is you know built up in the
animated series like we're talking about
to be this emotionless but still I mean
kunuk let's talk about kkona kkona which
is another way to humanize him but I
thought we had enough of that with Nora
already yeah but that was just a little
extra thing like he's still kind of what
you guys think Connect did you guys like
connect necessarily it was another one
of those elements I meant like where if
you would like you were creating a
bigger story you know I mean if it was a
little bit longer and you had a little
bit more time to develop the
relationship between her and and Barbara
Gordon yeah yeah I mean then you would
feel a little bit more like he was being
like betrayed by mr. freezer you're not
even like but she immediately was like
oh this kid just helped me yeah so
Barbara let's talk a little bit about
record in this so after seeing Killing
Joke
it was people interact now it's just
like especially with dick there that is
the relationship that works so easily
can I just say that if there's a ship or
whatever let's talk about the Dick
Grayson and Barbara Gordon ship
I mean it's great because it ultimately
doesn't work out right which is which is
it shouldn't work out but as them you
know as they were younger and under
Batman stuff that's perfect they should
that should be explored more I want more
of that so what did you think of those
two relationship it was sort of in the
background I think that's one of things
that could have fleshed out yeah
actually because I really was I was more
focused on Mr Freeze so like I'm just
having like a little bit in the
background where I was like hey let's go
up the coast for the weekend like I was
fine with it yeah I didn't really need
more are you but I also like you know
like knowing the animated series knowing
their background I don't know if maybe
coming into this people would get that
like not having watched anything else
like if they were just watching this
mm-hmm I don't know I don't think anyone
just I don't know anyone who would just
just saw sub-zero but I mean I'm sure I
don't either but I'm sure there's
someone but yeah I mean I think it's
it's a nice for the most part little
microcosm of the series I guess I mean
if nothing else it should get you into
the series because that's where
everything is fantastic so that's a good
point yeah well what do you think Jim of
the of the dick grace and Barbara goring
relationship in general do you think
that works um I I think it works in this
in the sense that it works because of it
ultimately doesn't work yeah you know
what I mean like like you said that's
sort of like you can understand there
being the attraction that that element
of the relationship but the fact that it
doesn't work out that makes sense you
know what I mean definitely and in more
than just like a one-night stand right
no exactly it's like we give it yeah
yeah Mary Kay Bergman voice back on this
and this is the only animated prod and
she voiced back role on she she commits
suicide in nineteen and unfortunately
this came out what ninety eight ninety
was like right after that's when news
came out unfortunately but she did a lot
of voices on early South Park episode I
was looking her up a little bit under
you've done a lot yeah she's in like
every she was like a voice acting
teacher and stuff
so I thought she was really
that was Batgirl I love the when dr.
Gregory whatever is shooting at her at
with the the the oil behind her and oh
yeah that's perfect yeah fuel tanks you
idiot I thought she was a really strong
Batgirl she's never voiced her in the
series or any other movies but I I would
have loved to hear her a little bit more
because she she tapped into something
different that I don't think Tara Strong
did or I can't remember the whoever
voiced back on the first couple seasons
of the animated series but yeah she
tapped into something different like she
was like more hard-nosed but still had
like the the really nice side with with
dick and everything yeah yeah it was a
it was an interesting change of pace cuz
you could tell that the voice is
different but still had you know it was
a good different like it was a good
unique kind of take on the character so
it would be cool if she was still around
to see her definitely would have yeah I
liked her a lot
so yeah let's talk about the music okay
so this is not Shirley Walker as you
know she did all the music on the
animated series and stuff and she's the
big reason why that sir was so sure was
so successful they brought in I'm not
sure how to pronounce this I'm sorry
Michael McKean from the kitchen I'm not
sure how to pronounce that but he did
the music and they're still pretty
strong music it's good yeah it's still
pretty epic feels cinematic and stuff
you know I kind of ranted a little bit
about The Killing Joke about how that
music wasn't up to snuff this felt like
pretty epic yeah what'd you guys think
of the music in this yeah I thought it
gave it more of an epic feel it was it
was a little you know a little bit
higher standard than the anime than the
actual show you know I mean I felt like
I said it it felt a little bit more
cinematic then definitely I think I
think a sign of a good score in general
too is when you don't necessarily like
notice it like a first viewing that's
kind of when it just fits so well that
you don't realize that it's kind of
manipulating you right and then you
realize it later yeah then you could
just listen to advice right
yeah I love film scores and stuff when
listening to those yeah this this was a
strong one it's just like fit and like
to the point where like I noticed it a
couple times but for the most part I
couldn't really tell you like where it
was at because it just fit right in
no I kind of feel the same way Yeah
right so there's that doctor I mentioned
earlier I think he's probably the
weakest part of this Gregory Belson yeah
cuz he's not like an evil guy he's just
a Greek yeah just kind of like what he's
telling Mr Freeze is like you know like
you got to get this person to get a
transplant he's like well it'll kill
them and he's like he's like yelled yeah
yeah yeah but yeah and then he's like
well this is gonna cost you you're like
you're just gonna okay he's just like
super jackass I guess yeah he's not
really a villain he's just a jerk doctor
right and I feel like he's in a week he
didn't give a lot too for mr. fries to
work off of in a sense you know I mean
like I felt like mr. Freeze's character
was actually a little weaker in this
than I'm even animates the animated so
you want to see that and maybe partly
because he wasn't he didn't have anybody
really interesting to work off of luck
he had the two polar bears and this guy
you know yeah so I don't know yeah I
kind of feel the same way like maybe if
even if I think it was a little longer I
don't know if they would have any of it
I say had enough to flush him out it was
just character this wasn't just kind of
lame yeah exactly no I think they could
have put someone else more interesting
yeah he was kind of a throwaway kind of
a character yeah I didn't really care
what happened right I did want to talk
about the the climax I really liked the
climax on the abandoned oil derrick just
that whole setting is really cool yeah
now the fire things up and incorporates
the animation looks great there's that
the very ending where Batman swinging
away on the rope on the batwing and he's
like spinning around I was like aw that
looks so good it's just so fluid looks
fantastic
what'd you guys think of that whole
climax and everything I think that if
you put it on another movie maybe a
little bit more of an interesting
that would have been a satisfying yeah
go back and save mister freidy that was
great such a dick like well yeah but
we're the good guys yeah babby I'm just
lifting it up like a boss yeah yeah I
know I thought like I said the action
sequences in the film I thought were
great they were beautifully laid out
right it was very reminiscent to me to
sort of like the climax of aliens you
know a lot of kind of callbacks to me
for that you know like they get to the
end and like oh where's the bed
wingman yeah that's kind but ya know I
thought it was cool like that and the
more the motorcycle chase sequence that
that were to like really beautiful yeah
I wanted to suggest for anyone who's
checking this out to go and watch a
heart of ice which is like mr. Freeze's
introduction in the animated series it's
one of the best episodes of that entire
series and almost every episode is great
yeah so that that one sticks out but
yeah it's it's it's it read does the the
origin of mr. freeze it's from the
animated series the whole nor his wife
being frozen giving him that humanity
and stuff that's all from that many
minutes series originally so yeah that's
all great stuff also there's an episode
called deep freeze that's also a great
episode the animated series which this
really feels like a continuation it
blends in like perfectly with that yeah
absolutely so yeah really quickly what
do you guys think of how they changed
mr. Freeze's because he was not exactly
a throwaway character but he was sort of
not one of the the best Batman villains
and they brought him up to here to be a
really unique cool villain so what do
you think of the animated series origin
of them well I like mr. freeze as a
character so I like an excuse to see
more of him and I like when they flushed
out his origin personally right you know
I got you yeah I know again I you know
like I was never like a huge mr. freeze
fan until the animated series and then
he was like elevated to one of my
favorite villains and then sports Mike
recovered and they gave him that origin
too and in the movies yeah
very strange but yeah he is he came off
as honestly probably one of the
strongest characters in the anime - yeah
which is weird to say because doesn't
show up all that much right he shows up
in like a handful of episodes I think
when you get a good character man you
got a good character yeah he's great
yeah
so bottom line we got more polar bears
yeah I'm gonna bring Mr Freeze back to
live action he does they have polar bear
guards yes great would you do like I
think they went of course they'd CGI
Verde then it just looked like the coke
right they could smile and drink Bobby
good have Benedict Cumberbatch play one
of them so he has to wear that weird
green okay
any last words about this one I like it
it's it's a definitely a good one to
have in your collection and it's a good
bansuri it's another good dimension it
shows her resourcefulness and sure that
she lead not just wants to go after how
competent she is even when she's not in
the big yeah as Barbara Gordon not just
as Batgirl and there was a bat kick kick
oh yeah I do
game last words yeah I would say check
it out I'm actually sorry that it took
so long for me to check it out I wish I
it's for summer so yeah this was the
first time I had seen it and like I said
I was a big fan of the animated series
and a big fan of mr. freeze from the
animated series so right it was kind of
cool to see that can like the basically
the kind of the end of his storyline in
a sense it was a good way to kind of cap
it off right that Batman Beyond episode
was called melton where he kind of comes
back which is a great episode of that
show so go ahead and check that out
yeah this is really good a little double
feature with massive phantasm a lot of
fun pic of the week this week I wanted
to suggest the Batman adventures I have
a trade here from a while back it's kind
of a random collection of stories
sort of a best-of of this line from a
while back there's a good four by Paul
Dini
think you'll enjoy so if you liked the
show you'll like this as well I mean it
flushes out certain things here and
there and it's just a lot of fun to see
that that carried those character models
on a comic book it's just fun and
different and I like it a lot so go
ahead and check out that whole line
specifically this one is just a sort of
a just random collection there's not
really a title or anything on it so the
Batman adventures I anytime you can pick
that up go ahead and check it out it's a
lot of fun and a good companion for the
animated series
okay so social medias Jim I know you've
you've been doing awesome build on the
YouTube channel here yeah and you also
have a fan page yeah you can find me on
James Jim Jerez on Facebook and yeah I
do stuff for a nostalgia critic so I
have a show on awesome a couple of
awesome builds I'm J awesome so yeah and
of course right here and Twitter and
Facebook
usual spot that you already talked you
can find me on Twitter and awesome
underscore Walter and we're talking of
course all the time we all talk about
the animated shows and the live-action
movies whatever is coming out super here
related conflict related talk to us
about it will be willing to do that okay
so until next week i'm pretty sure
porter will be back I know some of you
guys have been missing it - totally
go ahead and like the Facebook page
facebook.com slash an awesome comic show
always exclusive videos on Thursdays so
go check that out and until next week
I'm Walter Bernays yak for these folks
they're fantastic and we'll see you on
the next page
you